another one bites the dust first it was
luna then three arrows capital celsius
voyager and now there's a new one vault
which is a crypto lending platform has
just collapsed they say they've
suspended withdrawals while their
investors try to figure out if they can
suspend paying rent and today we're
gonna find out what that means for you
as we watch crypto lenders exchanges and
hedge funds blowing up left and right
like a bad michael bay movie you might
be asking yourself who's next and who
can you trust the first answer to that
question of course being yours truly
coffeezilla bump the stock never rugged
before probably never will but the
second answer to that question is really
nobody else i really wouldn't trust
anyone with your cryptocurrency and
today i want to explain why see the
crypto winter has shown us anything it's
the interconnected nature of crypto and
not in a good way more like in an
alabama family reunion way where
everyone is a little too related now of
course when crypto's going great
everybody's doing well but the problem
is when crypto's not doing so great
things like luna happen everything just
sort of seems to go down at the same
time and i'm not talking about crypto
prices here i'm not here to cry because
bitcoin down i mean yes it is and yes
the only thing michael saylor's about to
be managing is a mcdonald's but i'm
talking about something else entirely
i'm talking about entire industries
grinding to a halt because some dudes
got access to a little too much leverage
i'm talking about three arrows capital
which we're going to have a full
breakdown on soon yacht tour and
everything but to sum it all up a lot of
crypto projects were exposed when a
single degenerate gambler who liked to
borrow a lot basically went under and
tried to take everyone out with him it's
been like watching one of those domino
competitions where they all start
falling at the same time and the only
survivor is a guy who looks like he's
about to go trick some hobbits now some
people have been calling this crypto
contagion and what they mean by that
basically is that one company collapses
and it infects all the other companies
and causes them to collapse too but the
question is what can we learn from this
very nerdy version of the walking dead
well it's quite simple actually it turns
out you can't trust other people with
your money especially not billionaires
there's a shock there's been a saying in
crypto that's been around for ages which
is not your keys not your coins and
while i hate to agree with a crypto bro
on basically anything
they're kind of right it just means if
you don't own the wallet where your
money is you don't own your own money
it's like the same sad movie on repeat
where people put their money in these
lending platforms or crypto exchanges
like voyager and suddenly they go bust
and people find out they don't actually
own the crypto they thought they own
what they own is an iou from their
crypto exchange but when that crypto
exchange becomes worthless so does the
iou and at that point it's just too late
you're not going to get your money back
instead they're going to use your money
to pay off an even bigger iou fu so
what's the answer if we can't trust our
glorious institutions not to gamble our
money away well one answer is that you
might want to own your own crypto which
i know sounds like a lot of work and
yeah that sucks but hey look at the
bright side if you ever make a stupid
investment like buying safe moon you
will truly own that stupid investment
you will truly own a piece of what is
arguably a billion dollar con don't you
want that for yourself i guess i'm not
really selling this very well but the
point is i'm really not here to sell it
at all and i'm not here to tell you guys
what wallet to get cold hot hardware or
not the point of this video is not any
of that there's tons of videos on that
already the point of this video is just
to explain why self-custody of your
money might be important to you and
that's not to say that i hate
centralization or anything i really do
understand the appeal but you also have
to understand that the main advantage of
centralized finance has always been is
always and was always protection for
example in fiat in america if your bank
goes bust you're fdic insured your money
is safe and naturally this is why people
love banks and bank robbing movies
because when they get robbed you're not
getting robbed your money is still safe
but this does not exist in crypto it's
the wild wild west so there's not the
same reason to keep your money with
someone else in fact instead of it being
a plus it's actually a minus because now
not only do you have to worry about you
making a stupid investment and losing
all your money now you have to worry
about the guy you put your money with
making a stupid investment and losing
all your money which obviously is more
common than we all thought and you might
be thinking well look the good news is i
don't put my money with stupid companies
i only trust safe established companies
like coinbase the problem here is that
the same rules apply just in may
coinbase admitted that if they go
bankrupt you could lose all the money
you store there and while i have to say
that coinbase claims that they have zero
risk of bankruptcy and i probably even
agree with that they're probably not
going to go under tomorrow i'm not sure
they will never go bust and that's sort
of the problem you might trust a
centralized exchange for a day a month
maybe even a year but do you really want
to trust a guy who looks like joe
rogan's son grew up in a float tank his
whole life forever
the answer is probably no now did that
joke land the answer is also probably no
because it's way too long anyways rant
over i hope that wasn't too much of a
soapbox in part because i don't even
know what a soapbox is i also hope you
guys don't panic out there this isn't
about scaring you into thinking that
your crypto's suddenly going to vanish i
just wanted to take a realistic look at
the fact that most centralized ways of
storing crypto is going to be more risky
than storing it yourself although i have
to say even storing crypto yourself has
risks too so for those of you who are
uncomfortable with all of that there's a
third option as well which i haven't
mentioned which is just sort of
not getting into crypto i mean i know
everyone's made it seem like you have to
own crypto in 2022 but honestly you
don't i think many people have been led
to believe that crypto is more regulated
and ready for the average investor than
it actually is the truth is no matter
what these terms and conditions of these
websites say there is no safety net yet
in cryptocurrency and it's okay to say
you don't want to play that game until
someone sets it up that's fine that's
the whole purpose of regulators which we
talk about all the time on this channel
and also if you want to roll the dice
with a crypto exchange after watching
this video or lender that's cool too
just be aware that there's no take back
seats you know i think a lot of people's
logic for storing their crypto there is
they think they're going to be the ones
to get out before it all goes bust and
maybe that's true but remember you can't
trust what these people say which makes
it hard to time these things i want to
bring your attention to one of the most
recent press releases of vold again
that's the people who recently went
under and suspended withdrawals so
imagine you have your money there for a
second right
just understand that only a couple weeks
before they announced they were
suspending all withdrawals they were
sending out this email hey we understand
that these are trying times for crypto
investors but vauld continues to operate
as usual despite volatile market
conditions we do not have any exposure
to celsius or three aeros capital and we
remain liquid despite market conditions
over the last few days all withdrawals
were processed as usual and this will
continue to be the case in the future so
obviously that was a big lie but you
wouldn't know it listening to volds
management who were saying that they
were completely safe except for the
small fact that they were completely
lying and that's sort of the problem
these crypto exchanges or lending
platforms are financially incentivized
to lie to you about their solvency let
me repeat that one more time they are
financially incentivized to lie to you
about their solvency you're never going
to hear one of them come out and say hey
we're in danger
which should probably be illegal by the
way to lie about the state of your
finances but anyways
either way it just is what it is and
there are several cases of investors
being persuaded by this in the case of
vault they thought they were safe and
now they're broke and i don't want you
guys to be broke i want you to be smart
or if you want to be stupid at least own
your stupid mistakes now that was going
to be the end of the video but it turns
out there's actually some updates so i
want to speed run those real quick it
turns out vauld the crypto linder that
suspended withdrawals is in talks of
getting acquired by nexo which could
kind of act as like a bailout so that's
good news for their customers um bad
news for voyager though they suspended
withdrawals and now have declared
chapter 11 bankruptcy so that's gonna be
a long ride for the investors it doesn't
change the point of this video points
are still the same
you can't trust these people but i did
want to make that quick update just for
accuracy anyways that's basically it
pump the stock thanks for watching and
i'll see you in the next one